was it was it ever a a video you started
making and thought no I just can't I
can't I can't finish this one or that
you just didn't you scrapped it for
whatever reason my second video ever and
that's the only time it happens I um i'
done the hunter hunter video and I was
like okay now I'll make a and I didn't
really talk about kilua in the hunter
hunter video Even though I [__] love
that character and I was like okay cool
I'll make a kilua video because you know
I've already recently you know rad and
rewatched a bunch of Hunter Hunter
Hunter and like it'll you know everyone
who already likes Hunter Hunter will
watch this video then and like that'll
work yeah and then I was
like but I don't want
to and then I was like and I also I
don't want to be like the hunter hunter
guy and I was like I think I'm more
excited to make a different video and
then I made a different video and that's
kind of been my whole
career's what's the video You' spent the
most time on because I like even for me
doing a half hour video is just I I
dread it sometimes just like even the
half run time I'm like this is so much
[__] work you've done like hour 2our
videos I would say probably the 2hour
video um so I had two 2hour videos one
was the unreality of pro wrestling which
is relatively recent right and or maybe
that was an hour and a half I can't
remember but the probably the biggest
one was why you should still read
berserk which was an absolute [__]
journey to make that video yeah yeah
because there are there are some shows
where I want to make a video on but I
just like I I I sit down to like try and
start writing the script and I'm like I
don't know if I can do this Justice you
know some like you know I'm sure people
will think I do justice but I you know
proving it to myself that I can make but
if you weren't a little bit
afraid like I I have to be I have to
feel that to make a video you know like
I I like that like [__] I don't know if
I can pull this off like that that that
will make me make a video cuz you just
you just got to ride the fear GS no I've
done that a few times but it's just like
it's been one of those videos where
where I've started I write a sentence
and then it's like a year-long process
of me like pying myself up to do this
and then I do it and then I'm like okay
that was great and then I'm like but I
got to do it again
baby again that's that's me with this
[__] o PP video I've been trying to
write for like 4 years and I just like I
just can't every time I rewrite or
reread the script I'm just like it's not
good enough yeah and and I think it's
just because like it's such an important
series for me where like a difficult one
to write about difficult one to write
about too especially without like giving
away spoilers and stuff like that you
know so it's just like I've just been
sitting on this video for like 4 years I
still get people coming up to me every
now and then being like so that Pon
video I hate talking about stuff and
working on people cuz sometimes you know
something just happens and something
doesn't pan out and people are really
excited about it and I'm like [__] I
shouldn't have said it yeah and I or I
or I could just pleasantly surprise them
when it comes out you know that's why
I've stopped that's why I've stopped
doing that as well you know it'll come
out when it will come out and if we got
to cook we got to don't even tell
exists comes out it comes out doesn't
doesn't you know so is on that topic is
there anything you want to do that you
haven't been able to do on YouTube yet
or anything like any dreams that you
want to do
so yeah there's there's some stuff um I
really want to do a video on the movie
Jingle All The Way which is the AR
Christmas movie and legitimately one of
the greatest movies of all
time I love the lengths they go to in
that film to get a [__] toy it is it
is a good movie [__] actually I think
I've rewatched that recently yeah I've
rewatched it recently every year for 30
years
um oh no no don't don't okay we can't
put that on there put that on there [__]
find out wow he really does have sh Moon
his name
yeah yeah that that is an amazing film
now that I think about I also made I
think probably the most unhinged video
I've ever made was called Space Jam 2 is
a lie oh my God I love that um
and I have a video that is a sequel to
that video but when you click on the
video you won't know it's a sequel to
the Space Jam 2 video until like 40
minutes in and that to me would
be like so [__] weird and it makes me
so excited to do it but it's like it's
kind
ofe yeah it would be um and I'd love
that because I know a certain percentage
of my audience would [__] hate it
that always makes me pretty excited yeah
you're just like at some point I think
you're like the most eloquent [__]
anime s or [__] just video s on
[__] YouTube and sometimes I just
think you're a massive Troll and I can't
decide which which side of the fence you
are I I don't know I have a question
where did you get your narrating style
from it's a really boring story but like
so I started doing YouTube and um I just
didn't know how to talk and so it's just
I it's it's just real monotone but then
I started getting comments from people
who English wasn't their first language
and particularly people who English
wasn't their first language who had
learned English in like America right
and they were saying that like I can't
really understand you a lot of the time
could you slow down and so I started
slowing down but then like when I
started talking slower my voice kind of
dropped an octave and then that kind of
became like this and it just naturally
went that way and it's weird because
like sometimes like whenever I see like
one of my videos Pierce like outside my
bubble yeah I get so I see so many
people being like why does he talk like
that
you know and um like Joey I saw you
recently or not recently but I got sent
a clip of you saying that I talked too
slowly in videos and that you speed up
my but but the thing is no no no
no no okay because sometimes I'm just
like all right I really want to know
what John's going to say on this topic
but I know the speed at which Super
IAT and sometimes I don't have two hours
to kill okay
so I'm just like sorry John I'm going to
up it just a tiny little bit see Joey I
know that you do that now so I have been
narrating all my videos at 75
speed even slow so that you are watching
at the
correct God damn it I I think like
ultimately at the end of the day it's
the way I like to narrate videos and
like I get it's not for everyone that's
cool but like I don't know if you guys
can tell from my videos I stopped trying
to please everyone a long [__] time
ago and I just like making them the way
I like making them if people want to
watch that's cool and people don't I
just love the Jerry call
out oh I've had that cooking the entire
podcast finally on the show now I can
say it I mean do do you feel that it's
do you care if anyone watches it like
1.25 or 1.5 or is it just well not
really like [__] life's hard to you got
to do you know like I like no the
creative inte the chiming I CH it's not
every video I do that with it's only the
long ones but no I mean like look if if
my videos provide any [__] enjoyment
to someone enjoy them however you want I
still watch them all the way through
okay so you got to give me credit for
that un like this guy yeah
exactly two minutes and exit's out it
was the one you know you know which one
I distinctly remember which one it was
um it was the one where you talked about
a horror manga with a girl or something
and someone dies and yeah and I was like
this sounds [__] sick I'm going to
read it and I
didn't and every single time I think
about reading it and I I I I'm like man
I can't click I can't keep clicking on
this video and clicking off it this is
psychotic YouTube's going to think I
hate this video um so yeah I I got to
read it I will I will a fantastic manga
you should read it it's very good you
want to talk about like human horror
yeah yeah that's what that's why you
really sold me on the concept of it and
for some reason I just haven't read it
uh I guess the next time you come on the
show I will make sure I've read it
that's a promise I promise I just have
to click on and off your videos so I'm
going to I'm going to try and not do
that as much um yeah you killing me here
Conor I I think I I YouTube though will
automatically put and I don't know why
it does this for me it'll it'll keep
replaying your goddamn Lial Space video
for me like like I I will leave my
YouTube on on the side and then 2 hours
later whatever I've left it for some
reason I'm back and I'm I'm an hour into
Lial space I'm like man they really want
me to watch I mean it helps like I I
have like a personal account on YouTube
it constantly recommends me my own
videos and my reaction is always like oh
[__] God I hate this guy I just don't
understand why it keeps recommending me
this one video like I'm like I'm
obsessed with li I don't even I don't
even watch anything about limal spaces I
don't I I've never watched it well how
would you know if you don't like it if
you haven't watched it no I've seen it
but I clearly don't search out for it or
click on many of the videos for some
reason your goddamn video keeps getting
Auto auto played for me I click off to
minutes in every single time I keep I
keep telling it this video is not for
me but I I did that for like some
someone else as well and it kept
replaying the like H bomber guy Roblox
video I don't know why I would finish a
video and it would autoplay that video
and even though i' watched it great
video but it was um no that's that's me
uh like I think I've talked about this
briefly before but that's me and like I
you should look out for this I swear it
does This I Swear YouTube does this
it'll keep recommending it'll keep Auto
playing one video yes so I fall asleep
to like certain videos uh and like
recently it's been like the history of
the universe where it's kind of like
I've told us about this before uh I
don't think I've finished a single video
cuz I cuz they're about an hour long I
get 20 minutes in and then i' I'm asleep
you get so much mileage out of one video
cuz I've fallen asleep four separate
times and then I'm like all right this
time this time I'll get further I get
like 25 minutes and then I'm like I
don't remember anything about the rest
of the video so one time I'm going to
like finish a video and know what theend
of the story is but until then it's
great it's very very interesting content
but also it's just so good to sleep too
yeah so calming right yeah it's so
calming yeah